and we have breaking news from Arizona
where police cornered a suspect they
believe killed at least three people
including a forensic psychiatrist who
worked for high-profile murder cases dr.
Steven Pitts who assisted with the
infamous JonBenet Ramsey investigation
was shot and killed on Thursday police
linked the killing with the murders of
two paralegals the next day and a fourth
killing may also be connected DeMarco
Morgan is here following the manhunt
DeMarco good morning John good morning
to you police say on Twitter they are
trying to contact the suspect at a hotel
in the Phoenix area dr. Stephen Pitts
was a well known to law enforcement
agents not only in Scottsdale but around
the entire country he helped them put a
lot of criminals behind bars it's highly
unusual for someone to wake up one
morning and say you know what today's
the day I want to become a serial killer
for decades investigators sought out dr.
Stephen Pitts for his insight into the
mind of a killer now it's his murder
police are trying to solve the 59 year
old forensic psychiatrist was shot
outside his office Thursday by a white
male suspect bald and wearing a dark hat
are we dealing with a serial killer here
we don't believe so we believe that
these shootings were not random
detectives suspect the same gunman
killed two paralegals that next day
Valerie sharp and Laura Anderson at a
law office about 10 miles away one of
the women who was shot in the head
managed to alert a bus driver before she
died officers that arrived on scene
quickly determined that there was a
blood trail and they followed it back to
the law office was it important to the
investigation that she was able to ask
for help because then that leads you to
another victim it did because if she
didn't make it outside of the business
to ask for help we may not have
discovered that crime scene when we did
police say they recovered evidence
linking the three murder victims they
were also trying to determine if
hypnotherapist and life coach Marsha
Levine is the gunman's fourth victim the
72 year old was shot dead in his office
Saturday not far from the other crime
scenes dr. Pitts body was found - less
than five miles away normally it would
be him talking to you about some murder
case not his own Jay Gooden and his
brother Scott were pit two lifelong
friends Scott
a former police officer in Florida
believes Pitt was murdered by someone
linked to one of his cases this was an
ambush
you know they waited for him to come out
and then they calmly walked away and
they did the same thing to those two
women at the law office police also tell
us that investigators have uncovered
other potential victims who could be in
danger and they are working with them to
keep them safe Nora
wow what a development DeMarco thank you
so much